de nouvelles tâches doivent être réalisées
et souvent, de nouveaux rôles doivent être remplis.
Le gâteau britannique :
il y a 300 ans, les gens travaillaient surtout dans des fermes ;
il y a 150 ans, dans des usines ;
aujourd’hui, la plupart des gens travaillent dans des bureaux.
Les gens évincés de tâches dans l’ancien gâteau
pouvaient tomber sur des tâches dans le nouveau.
Les économistes appellent ces effets des complémentarités,
mais ce n’est qu’un mot raffiné pour capturer la façon différente
dont le progrès technologique aide les êtres humains.
Résoudre ce mythe de Terminator
nous montre qu’il y a deux forces en jeu :
la substitution par les machines qui nuit aux travailleurs,
mais aussi ces complémentarités qui font le contraire.
Le second mythe
que j’appelle le mythe de l’intelligence.
Qu’ont en commun les tâches de conduite d’une voiture,
d’établissement d’un diagnostic et d’identification éclair d’un oiseau ?
Ce sont des tâches que, jusqu’à très récemment,
d’éminents économiques pensaient ne pas être facilement automatisables.
Pourtant, aujourd’hui, toutes ces tâches peuvent être automatisées.
Les grands constructeurs automobiles ont des programmes de voitures autonomes.
Il y a d’innombrables systèmes pouvant diagnostiquer des problèmes médicaux.
Il y a même une application qui peut identifier un oiseau
en un éclair.
Ce n’était pas de la malchance de la part des économistes.
Ils avaient tort
et la raison à cela est très importante.
Ils ont cru au mythe de l’intelligence,
la croyance selon laquelle les machines doivent copier la façon
de penser et de raisonner des êtres humains
afin de les surpasser.
Quand ces économistes essayaient de déterminer
quelle tâche les machines ne savaient pas faire,
ils pensaient que pour automatiser une tâche,
il fallait prendre un être humain,
qu’il vous explique comment il effectuait une tâche
puis essayer de refléter cette explication
dans un jeu d’instructions qu’une machine suivrait.
Cette vision a aussi été populaire en intelligence artificielle.
Je le sais car Richard Susskind,
qui est mon père et mon coauteur,
a eu son doctorat dans les années 80
sur le sujet de l’intelligence artificielle et la loi
à l’université d’Oxford
et était un avant-gardiste.
Avec un professeur, Phillip Capper,
et un éditeur juridique, Butterworths,
ils ont créé la première intelligence artificielle en droit
disponible sur le marché.
C’était le design de la page d’accueil.
Il m’a assuré que c’était un design cool à l’époque.
(Rires)
Il ne m'a jamais convaincu.
Il l’a publié sous la forme de deux disquettes,
à l’époque où les disquettes étaient molles,
et il avait la même approche que les économistes :
prenez un avocat,
demandez-lui de vous expliquer comment résoudre un problème légal
et essayez de refléter cette explication dans un jeu de règles que la machine suit.
En économie, si les êtres humains savent s’expliquer ainsi,
les tâches sont appelées des routines et peuvent être automatisées.
Mais si les êtres humains ne savent pas s’expliquer,
les tâches sont des non routines et sont vues comme hors d’atteinte.
Aujourd’hui, cette distinction entre routine et non routine est répandue.
Pensez à combien vous entendez des gens dire
que les machines effectuent juste des tâches prévisibles ou répétitives,
suivant des règles ou bien définies.
Ce ne sont que des mots différents pour désigner une routine.
Ce sont des cas classiques de tâches de non routine.
Revenons-en à ces trois cas que j’ai évoqués au début.
Demandez à un médecin comment il établit un diagnostic médical
et il pourra vous donner quelques règles de bon sens,
mais il aura du mal.
Il dira que cela requiert créativité, jugement et intuition.
Ce sont des choses difficiles à formuler
alors nous pensions que ces tâches seraient difficiles à automatiser.
Si un être humain ne sait pas l’expliquer,
où commencer pour écrire un jeu d’instructions
que la machine puisse suivre ?
Il y a 30 ans, cette perspective était correcte,
mais aujourd’hui, elle semble douteuse
et à l’avenir, elle sera fausse.
Les progrès en puissance de traitement, en capacité de stockage de données
et en conception algorithmique
rendent cette distinction entre routine et non routine
de moins en moins utile.
Pour voir cela, revenez-en à l’établissement d’un diagnostic médial.
Cette année,
une équipe de chercheurs à Stanford a annoncé avoir développé un système
qui peut vous dire si une tache de rousseur est cancéreuse
avec la même exactitude que les meilleurs dermatologues.
Comment cela marche-t-il ?
Il n’essaye pas de copier le jugement ou l’intuition d’un docteur.
Il ne connaît ni ne comprend rien du tout à la médecine.
Il exécute un algorithme de reconnaissance de formes,
parcourant 129 450 cas déjà traités
à la recherche de similarités entre ces cas-là
et la lésion en question.
Il effectue ces tâches de façon non humaine,
en se reposant sur l’analyse de plus de cas possibles
qu’un docteur ne peut espérer examiner durant sa vie.
Peu importe que cet être humain,
ce docteur, n’ait pas su expliquer comment il a effectué la tâche.
Il y a ceux qui s’attardent sur le fait
que ces machines ne sont pas conçues à notre image.
Par exemple, prenez Watson d’IBM,
le superordinateur qui a participé à un jeu télévisé américain en 2011
et a battu deux champions humains du jeu.
Le jour après sa victoire,
le Wall Street Journal a publié un article du philosophe John Searle
ayant pour titre « Watson ignore qu’il a gagné à Jeopardy »
C’est brillant et c’est vrai.
Watson n’a pas crié de joie.
Il n’a pas appelé ses parents pour dire ce qu’il avait accompli.
Il n’est pas allé boire un verre dans un bar.
Ce système n’essayait pas d’imiter la manière de jouer des humains,
mais peu importe.
Il les a quand même battus.
Résoudre le mythe de l’intelligence
montre que notre compréhension limitée de l’intelligence humaine,
de notre façon de penser et raisonner,
est moins une contrainte en automatisation qu’elle ne l’était auparavant.
De plus, nous l’avons vu,
quand ces machines réalisent des tâches différemment des êtres humains,
il n’y a pas de raison de penser
que ce que les êtres humains sont capables de faire
représente le sommet
de ce que ces machines pourraient être capables de faire à l’avenir.
Le troisième mythe
est ce que j’appelle le mythe de la supériorité.
On dit souvent que ceux qui oublient
le côté utile du progrès technologique,
ces complémentarités mentionnées auparavant,
se prêtent au sophisme de la masse fixe de travail.
Le sophisme de la masse fixe de travail
est lui-même un sophisme
que j’appelle le sophisme du sophisme de la masse fixe de travail,
ou SSMFT, pour faire court.
Laissez-moi expliquer.
Ce sophisme est une idée très ancienne.
C’est un économiste britannique, David Schloss,
qui lui a donné son nom en 1892.
Il était perplexe d’avoir rencontré un docker
qui utilisait une machine pour faire des rondelles,
les petits disques en métal se plaçant au bout des vis.
Ce docker se sentait coupable d’être plus productif.
La plupart du temps, on s’attend au contraire,
se sentir coupable de ne pas être productif,
un peu trop de temps passé sur Facebook ou Twitter au travail.
Mais ce docker se sentait coupable d’être plus productif
et quant au pourquoi, il a dit : « J’agis mal.
Je prends le travail d’un autre homme. »
Dans son esprit, il y avait une masse de travail fixe
à diviser entre lui et ses camarades
et en utilisant la machine pour faire plus,
ses camarades auraient moins à faire.
Schloss a vu l’erreur.
La masse de travail n’était pas fixe.
Ce docker utilisant la machine et devenant plus productif,
le prix des rondelles chuterait, la demande augmenterait,
il faudrait faire plus de rondelles
et ses camarades auraient plus de travail.
La masse de travail augmenterait.
Schloss a appelé cela « le sophisme de la masse fixe de travail ».
Les gens parlent du sophisme de la masse fixe de travail
pour l’avenir de tous types de travaux.
Il n’y a pas de masse fixe de travail à diviser
entre les gens et les machines.
Oui, les machines substituent les humains, diminuant la masse de travail initiale,
mais elles complémentent les humains
et la masse de travail augmente et change.
Mais SSMFT.
Voici l’erreur :
le progrès technologique
n’augmente pas la masse de travail.
Certaines tâches ont plus de valeur, de nouvelles tâches émergent.
Il est faux de penser
que les humains seront nécessairement mieux placés pour réaliser ces tâches.
C’est le mythe de la supériorité.
Oui, la masse de travail peut augmenter et changer,
mais les machines devenant plus compétentes,
il est probable qu’elles assument cette masse de travail supplémentaire.
Le progrès technologique, au lieu de complémenter les humains,
complémente les machines.
Pour l’observer, revenez-en au fait de conduire une voiture.
Les systèmes de navigation par satellite complémentent les êtres humains.
Ils font de certains humains de meilleurs conducteurs.
Mais à l’avenir,
le logiciel va remplacer les êtres humains sur le siège conducteur
ces systèmes de navigation ne complémenteront pas les humains,
mais amélioreront les voitures sans conducteur,
aidant plutôt les machines.
Revenez-en à ces complémentarités indirectes également mentionnées.
Le gâteau économique s’agrandira,
mais les machines s’améliorant,
les nouvelles demandes pourront être des biens que les machines,
et non les humains, seront les mieux placées pour produire.
Le gâteau pourrait changer,
mais, les machines s’améliorant,
elles pourraient être mieux placées pour réaliser les tâches nécessaires.
En bref, la demande pour des tâches
n’est pas la demande pour du travail humain.
Les humains n’en bénéficieront
que s’ils gardent la main sur ces tâches complémentées,
mais les machines s’améliorant, cette probabilité diminue.
Que nous disent ces trois mythes ?
Résoudre le mythe de Terminator
nous montre que l’avenir du travail dépend de cet équilibre entre deux forces :
la substitution par les machines nuisant aux travailleurs,
mais aussi ces complémentarités qui font le contraire.
Jusqu’à maintenant, cet équilibre est en faveur des êtres humains.
Résoudre le mythe de l’intelligence
montre que la substitution par les machines,
monte en puissance.
Les machines ne savent pas tout faire,
mais elles peuvent faire plus,
empiétant plus sur le royaume des tâches réalisées par des êtres humains.
Il n’y a pas de raison de penser que
ce que les humains peuvent faire actuellement
représente une ligne d’arrivée,
que les machines s’arrêteront poliment
une fois aussi compétentes que nous.
Rien de tout cela n’importe
tant que ces vents bénéfiques de la complémentarité
soufflent assez fort,
mais résoudre le mythe de la supériorité
montre que ce processus d’empiétement sur les tâches
ne fait pas que renforcer la force de substitution par les machines,
mais use également ces complémentarités bénéfiques.
Réunissez ces trois mythes
et nous aurons un aperçu de cet avenir inquiétant.
Les machines continuent de s’améliorer,
empiétant de plus en plus sur les tâches réalisées par les êtres humains,
augmentant la force de substitution par les machines,
amenuisant la force de la complémentarité avec les machines.
À un moment donné, cet équilibre sera en saveur des machines
plutôt que des êtres humains.
C’est le chemin que nous suivons.
Je dis « chemin » délibérément car nous n’y sommes pas encore,
mais il est dur d’éviter de conclure que c’est la direction que nous prenons.
C’est la partie inquiétante.
Laissez-moi vous dire pourquoi je crois que c’est un bon problème à avoir.
Durant la plupart de l’histoire humaine, un problème économique a dominé :
comment agrandir assez le gâteau économique pour que tout le monde en vive.
Au début du premier siècle après J.C.,
en prenant le gâteau économique mondial
et en le divisant en parts égales,
chacun aurait quelques centaines de dollars.
Presque tout le monde vivait sous ou autour du seuil de pauvreté.
En avançant de 1 000 ans,
c’est toujours à peu près vrai.
Mais durant les derniers siècles, la croissance économique a décollé.
La taille de ces gâteaux économiques a explosé.
Le PIB mondial par habitant,
la valeur de ces parts individuelles du gâteau d’aujourd’hui
est d’environ 10 150 dollars.
Si la croissance économique continue à 2 %,
nos enfants auront deux fois nos richesses.
Si elle continue au rythme d’un pour cent,
nos petits-enfants auront deux fois nos richesses.
Nous avons résolu le problème économique traditionnel.
Le chômage technologique, s’il se produit,
sera un symptôme de ce succès.
Nous aurons résolu un problème, agrandir le gâteau,
mais l’aurons remplacé par un autre,
comment s’assurer que chacun ait une part.
D’autres économistes ont remarqué
que résoudre ce problème ne sera pas simple.
Pour la plupart des gens,
leur emploi est leur place à la table économique
et, dans un monde avec moins ou pas de travail,
il ne sera pas clair comment obtenir sa part.
Il y a par exemple beaucoup de discussions
sur diverses formes de revenu de base universel
en tant qu’approche possible
et il y a des essais en cours
aux États-Unis, en Finlande et au Kenya.
C’est le défi collectif auquel nous faisons face :
découvrir comment cette prospérité matérielle
générée par notre système économique
peut bénéficier à tous
dans un monde où notre mécanisme traditionnel
pour partager le gâteau,
le travail effectué par les gens,
s’étiole voire disparaît.
Résoudre ce problème va nécessiter que nous pensions différemment.
Il y aura beaucoup de désaccords sur ce qu’il faut faire,
mais nous devons nous souvenir que c’est un meilleur problème à avoir
que celui qui a hanté nos ancêtres durant des siècles :
comment faire grossir ce gâteau ?
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)